also here tonight Republican guys from
that gate so far that keep Republican
member of the House Judiciary Committee
congressman thanks for coming in thanks
for having me as you hear Victor lay all
that out I'm reminded of Al Green the
Democrat who some weeks and months ago
suggested can't beat Donald Trump at the
ballot box in 2020 have to impeach him
when you look at how the economy is
playing out this week and how this
impeachment drama is playing out your
thoughts very strange and you also see
impeachment really serve as the
substitute for an agenda for the
American people
Democrats haven't been fulfilling their
commitments on trade on health care on
the economy and so impeachment has
really been the alternative to that and
it's been all-consuming as an obsession
and it's a little bizarre to just harken
back to a few weeks ago when Eric's wall
well called the president's conduct a
crime spree in progress and Jerry Nadler
said nothing was more urgent and now
Nancy Pelosi is I guess sitting on the
impeachment articles like they're an egg
that she's waiting to hatch at any
moment well if there's a crime spree why
haven't the articles been sent to the
Senate so the president could be brought
to a trial well that's obviously the
contradiction that we see through the
Democrats and it's sort of hard to take
this team seriously when as you pointed
out in your monologue you had Democrats
in concert with folks like Rachel Maddow
trying to breathe truth into a dossier
that we had been telling the American
people was false so the Democrats and
their allies and the media were wrong
really on two fronts one the underlying
veracity or truth of the dossier
Horowitz testifies that it's steel sub
sources who say well that's not what we
tell steel why we don't know why that
ended up in the document and then second
the extent to which that dossier was
used
you had Maddow and Schiff and others
saying oh the FBI did nothing wrong
there they totally followed the FISA
process we now see that dossier was the
central part of their application for
for surveillance well you took me right
where I wanted to go next which is one
thing for people in the media to be
called out and be held accountable for
mistakes and we all make them but this
was a big one and you go beyond that
Adam Schiff who you just invoked a
moment ago he went much further he's not
in the meeting he's in Congress been
elected by people in his district as you
know and he's chairman of a very
powerful committee and yet this
Washington Post piece begin
in 2017 with rachel maddow interview
Adam Schiff interviewing Adam Schiff any
sort of side steps the question of the
veracity of the dossier as you know and
we know now the shift memo was false
shouldn't we be holding Committee
Chairman very powerful committees to a
higher standard
absolutely you'll remember when Devin
Nunez put out his memo and shift put out
his response
you heard the mainstream media say oh
the Nunez memo has now been debunked by
the shift memo this is obviously the
truth well we now have something that we
rarely get in Washington politics an
actual verdict an actual result from the
Obama appointed inspector general saying
Nunez was right all along Schiff was
wrong now why does that matter
Schiff is not just a member of Congress
he's a member of the gang of eight so
there's intelligence as an armed
services committee member that I cannot
see but I have to rely on Schiff and
others in the gang of eight to correctly
assess that intelligence and give us
their accurate perceptions it's one of
the reasons why I have filed legislation
expressing the sense of the house that
shift should be removed as the
intelligence chairman so that we at
least get clear eyes on the most
important intelligence analysis that
faces the country congressman last
question Kim Strasser The Wall Street
Journal had a piece suggesting that
maybe Pelosi wants a quote unquote
rolling impeachment that she's holding
these articles waiting for something
else to drop and almost just hang it
over the President's head ahead of the
election your thoughts Democrats are
becoming the one-hit wonder where it's
only impeachment now I guess they've got
like postpartum depression because
they've birth this impeachment out and
they're sad that they won't be able to
continue to litigate it but it what's
strange about this politically ed is
that the more they talk about
impeachment and open hearings the worse
things get for them the
RealClearPolitics polling average on
impeachment inverted when Democrats
started holding public hearings because
the American people got to see how thin
their case was they should be through at
this we should all have a New Year's
resolution to be done with impeachment
and investigations and let's actually
put the American people first let's make
their agenda our agenda and not just
fuel political ambition congressman
you're very optimistic heading into the
new year we'll see how that plays out we
appreciate you coming in thank you